and tobin our clan what would the Nobel
Committee try to achieve by giving the
price to these three female candidates
to give much more attention to one of
the big challenge that we have in the
world today namely that violence against
women and rape has become a tool in wars
many places and that women has to play a
much bigger role in peace process and in
peace building who will you characterize
this year's decision by the committee it
is a very important signal to women all
over the world to take even more part in
the struggle for peace so today Arabic
word yes and it's a strong signal to the
entire Arabic Arab world that one cannot
set aside the women if you want a big
build a democracy and to solve all the
country complex a there were more than
250 nominees this year what was most
difficult for the committee before you
ended up with these three female winners
well to exclude many other good
candidates but we are come to the
conclusion that this is the most
important thing that we can give this
year which which criteria in of
Annabel's testament his will has been
most relevant for the committee when you
decided to give the prize to these
trained in a when well I would say all
the three criteria one is that these two
women in Liberia they contributed to
resolving a conflict around the table
and peaceful secondly they
has have contributed to building what
Alfred Nobel called brotherhood between
nations and certainly they have also
contributed to one of the other criteria
namely to disarmament this is a
disarmament of violence which is very
equally important as the tournament or
weapons this year's Nobel Peace Prize be
compared to the one in 1976 when Betty
Williams and Maura Corrigan for northern
Island receive the prize yes you can if
you want they also there like a quite
important role in the peace process
which the Nobel Committee at the time
pointed out are you can wins that all
three winners will come to us low on
December the 10th yearn for the ceremony
that will never know I'm not be hope so
you said them beforehand that you were
sure that this year's decision by the
committee would be met by recognition
and enthusiasm from people all over the
world are you quite sure that you are
right yes I am because this has been
such an important issue on the
international agenda and also in the UN
Security Council and ten million Swedish
Krona is the price that means that they
will divide the price the prize amount
between these three we're winners yes in
equal parts Thank You Metta yoga
you